but your first role I remember seeing
you in as well is A League of Their Own
right yeah I
have your kids
well you know what's funny my kids have
no interest in my career in any capacity
never have yeah yes you understand so I
like you when I started my show had a
little toddler running around and um you
know they never saw anything I took them
to see Tarzan when it I was Turk I was
the monkey in that and um so my son is
sitting there he's four and the other
baby is two Chelsea and and in the
middle of the movie there's a quiet part
and he stands on his chair he goes that
monkey's my mama
whole thing and I was like yes I didn't
know you would get them but my son who's
23 Blakey who uh is such a he's just
such a mush this kid he comes home from
a party he goes mom you're not going to
believe this I said what happened he
said John had on uh some movie and you
were like a teenager playing baseball
and you sounded like Sylvester Stallone
away I go blankie that's my most famous
movie that's how I became an Entertainer
because of that movie and he said yeah I
never saw it but it was weird seeing you
that young oh my God it is we I never
really thought about that about our kids
looking back like especially there's so
many YouTube videos and so many Clips to
look at right and they're so old now my
kids go from 27 25 23 19 and 9. I have a
nine-year-old I adopted at 50. I thought
I could get a facelift or a baby so I
took the baby you know kept me young in
a different way and so how do you think
your parenting has changed over the last
year like from the older ones to the new
you know so much first of all you know
when you grow up in a you know my mom
had died and we didn't have that much
money and my dad was you know troubled
guy and so I wanted to provide for my
children every kind of thing for
childhood that I didn't have like you
know we had those sneakers that were
attached in the store so you could never
100 you could try them on and like yeah
you have to do this thing yeah yeah oh
yeah they fit good Mom yeah they fit
good that you couldn't tell you can take
the tag off now yes so we you know I
wanted to give them everything my older
ones you know when I was a young mother
in my early 30s yeah and I come to find
out now as a 60 year old mother of a
nine-year-old that making the world so
smooth and without a bump for them
doesn't serve them and adulthood it
really doesn't and I was much too much
of a lenient mother with my older ones
and
um much too much in trying to repair my
own childhood through mothering them wow
and now I have a little daughter who has
autism she's nine years old and uh you
know her autism is is magical to me
because it forces me sort of to slow
down to take the time to really see the
world from another person's perspective
and you have to because it's like she
came with an operating system that my
computer didn't understand you know so
we had to sort of figure out how to be
there for each other and and how to make
her seen and um I know autism is often a
horrific diagnosis for some families and
some children it's just the the flavor
that I got of this little baby is is
such a good fit with me and and yeah you
know I always say I go to Tech get her
tested every few years because everybody
says to me she doesn't have autism I'm
like okay but she does they're like no
she doesn't she speaks so well I'm like
that's not right well there's different
yeah there's a whole variety of ways and
um so when I take her to get tested I go
she's mild now right not moderate she's
mild now they go no she's moderate still
going to be moderate gonna be moderate
our whole life it's a brain set up it's
there's nothing you can do but you know
it's it's a magical
different way of living it's like an
alien dropped from above into my life
yeah and I've learned to speak the
language and I love it I think that's
really good yeah it's amazing I love you
to meet her yeah well our daughters are
on the same age it would be great and my
this is how my daughter introduces
herself to the world anyone she walks
straight up to a kid on a plane I'm
River do you want to be friends and like
literally like literally like there's no
requirement she doesn't require you to
do anything that just you have to exist
it's so funny she loves people she well
she gets that honestly yeah she gets
that from you right yeah we were at a
hotel in the big hotel pool and I was
sitting in the lounge watching her swim
and swims up to everyone and all of a
sudden I hear like this is like in the
distance Rosie O'Donnell and I look and
she's smiling and waving and with this
whole family and I go come here what are
you doing she goes well I told them that
you know my daughter does okay so I say
to her honey you don't have to tell
everyone I'm your mommy they're gonna
love you for you you don't have to tell
them she goes Mom it works for me
oh
she was like but they get my daughter I
told her we were literally in a pool and
then she ends up telling this woman and
I'm at the other in the pool I'm like hi
and yeah she tells her she's like well
they get excited it's fun yeah and I'm
like okay but I don't want to shame her
for it but I'm like can you stop yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]